so i got a really good piece of advice
which was um always start with your
people
i remember pretty much everything i've
learned in fundraising has been some
point in time where an investor or a
friend or an advisor or another founder
said you're an idiot andrew
uh don't do this do this so what they
said was um start with your people
and the reason they said start with your
people is that it's essentially a
credibility slide you're essentially
making the argument that if you have
excellent folks then you've
demonstrated an ability to recruit and
if you've demonstrated an ability to
recruit you can largely solve
most problems within the realm of the
space that you're working in
so we kind of start with instead of a
bunch of faces um
we start with sort of experience in what
they did as an approximation and then we
also talk about who we are backed by
which obviously if you're earlier stage
you'll care less about kind of the
backed by and more about who your folks
are
after this slide if you do this first
they will take everything else you say
with whatever credibility you establish
here i'm a big fan of leading with
product
i think jason you also make this
argument all the time in fact i think
you were the one that taught me
we were vying for a spot at launch
festival
and uh rob grazioli who's also on our
board
one of my co-founders and i were
presenting or pitching to
the launch team and jason uh
said who in this room we finished and he
said who in this room thinks that what
density is doing is amazing
and like every hand went up and then he
said
who in this room understands what
density
how density does it and every hand went
down
he was like andrew where the hell is the
product you know start with their
product so anyway i
strongly encourage you to start with
your product and i also strongly
encourage you not to show envision links
or static graphics like i'm showing you
here but uh to actually show moving
stuff so typically this moves and shows
sort of count
uh we build a system that shows you how
many humans are in space we essentially
turn physical space into analytics
by counting the humans in it and we do
that with a
an entry based system and an open area
based system that's radar-based and
depth-based
but that's sort of irrelevant to
fundraising start with product otherwise
you're going to have to go back to and
revisit what it is that you do
also how you make money like what is
your model
is really helpful in our case we sell
our device
and we sell predominantly software so
the subscription that goes on top of
that
this is all typically moving and again
i'm sorry that i'm showing the static
images but this is sort of a
slightly redacted version of our deck so
showing actual interface moving there's
a great thing you can do in keynote
where you can load in a
move file do that and just show the
application
moving it will speak volumes
to where you are as a as a company
if you've only got screenshots to
screenshots but you really shouldn't
when you're fundraising you should
really be building product before your
fundraising